[DRUMS PLAYING]
ETHAN THAI: So right now, we're
sweeping a 100-foot by 100-foot
area with metal detectors
looking for things,
such as iron, musket
shot, canister,
any remnants of the battle.
NATHAN ARRINGTON:
We are here today
at the Princeton Battlefield
with Humanities 350,
a course called
"Battle Lab," whose goal
is to investigate the
Princeton Battlefield,
to teach students about
archaeology hands on,
and to get them to engage
with cultural heritage
and preservation right
here in their own backyard.
RACHAEL DELUE: Nathan said,
hey, how about a class where we
excavate something near campus?
And he said, what about
the Princeton Battlefield?
And I said, that's perfect.
You're an archaeologist.
I am an art historian that
studies early America.
What if we bring our
methods together,
what if we bring the
tools of our trade
together, to see if we can
unlock the Battle of Princeton
to bring new information,
new knowledge,
and make the picture of what
really happened here that day
more clear?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLARE COOK: There's definitely
a really wide variety
of majors represented in the
class, which is pretty cool.
So there's people like me
that had no archaeology --
and I haven't taken any
other history classes here --
and then there's
other people who
are in the archaeology
certificate program
or have done history.
So it is really neat to
get different insights
into those things.
RACHAEL DELUE: I work on
the history of American art,
and working on the
history of American art
means that I have to be a
specialist in American history.
And so I'm always thinking about
the larger contexts in which
art is produced, and
Princeton's museum
owns an incredibly
interesting painting
by Charles Willson Peale
of George Washington
at the Battle of Princeton.
CLARE COOK: So
yeah, there is a lot
of interesting things
from the painting
that I don't think I
would have noticed myself.
So I understood that, back
then, you could actually
see Nassau Hall from
the battlefield,
and this is even
reflected in some
of the artwork we've looked at.
A lot of times, the battle
is portrayed from the field,
but you can see Nassau
Hall in the background.
NATHAN ARRINGTON:
Across the road,
we're doing metal detection,
very systematic metal detection
to try to recover
artifacts from the battle,
but also from the periods
before and after the battle.
[METAL DETECTOR SOUNDING]
ETHAN THAI: We could have
something else right here.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
[BEEP]
Here we go.
ETHAN THAI: So this is a cut
nail, an extremely rusted cut
nail.
Having not taken a history
class in quite a long time,
I thought it'd be good
to just learn more
about the American Revolution,
the start of this nation.
But also alongside
with that, I do
enjoy the mechanical,
the technical side
of things too and using
technology like ground
penetrating radar earlier,
metal detectors here,
and other tools in the
excavation, archaeology field.
It's a great intersection
of everything.
NATHAN ARRINGTON: A
ground penetrating radar
is a noninvasive way to
cover a lot of territory
and try to find out some
more information about what
happened here and how
it was interpreted.
RACHAEL DELUE: We want students
to have moments where they're
digging deep into time
and into the past,
and they confront something
that is wholly unfamiliar
and have these transformative
moments when they're there
looking at something
that they thought
was simply a plot of grass.
And by excavating it both
literally and metaphorically,
they're encountering
something altogether new.
And that's transformative
in the sense
that, all of a
sudden, their world
becomes a different
one -- their world now,
but also their sense of
their place in history.
So excavation here is literal
as well as metaphorical.
It's a matter of what it
means to produce knowledge,
but also self-awareness
and a sense of ourselves
as humans in the 21st century.
[MUSIC PLAYING]